explain to me why nfts aren't [ __ ]
when new things come along there's an
incredible opportunity for [ __ ] it
creates an opportunity for hucksters to
take advantage i actually don't think
that every one of them understands that
they're doing [ __ ] behavior they're
completely confident a bunch of [ __ ]
people are gonna buy a squirrel with a
taco up its ass for four thousand
dollars as an image
it's not a jpeg because it's not on the
internet it's an nft because it's on the
blockchain i understand why people think
it's a jpeg everyone's bringing their
internet brain to the chains when a jpeg
on the internet is not owned by anything
because it's centralized thus you don't
own it on the blockchain it's
decentralized and that jpeg slash nft
can do [ __ ] what it does is based on the
execution 99 of nft projects are going
to be garbage so it's not nfts it's
crypto punks or board apes bingo nfps in
the macro are 100 the technology's too
big the individual projects within them
it's like saying social media doesn't
work no it doesn't work for you because
you're not charismatic smart or
attractive got you